Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and make
the material function for the wood. And then we're going to
bring all things together, such as the material function for
the moss, and put it into our parent material. So let's get
started. In the last video, you saw me make the moss
material and get that set up. So we're going to speed
things up a little bit. And we're going to copy what's
already there. Because you at this point, you should know how
to set these material, but work with material function, how
to set it up. And we're going to grab all of these, and we'll
include the make return attribute. Let's go and copy
this from the existing example. And you can feel free to do so
also. And let's go ahead and make a new material underneath
our material section, go to advance and go to material
function. And this material function, we will call this new
wood, if you haven't done this already. So we're going to
go in here. And also we need a parent material. So let's go and
do that. Now let's make our parent material if you haven't
already. And we'll call this m underscore blend, we can say
new blend, so you don't get it mixed up with any samples,
new blend. There you go. And you don't necessarily have to
have a map, but I have mine on there. I'm going to double
click on that new one. Let's go and move this one over our
material function for it. I'm going to zoom out just a
little bit. And I'm going to paste what we copied. And I'll
move the output over. And I'll drag this string into here. If
you want to feel free, you can leave my notes in here or
not. I do want to point out let's go full screen for a
second. I do want to point out the normal multiplier, you'll
see in here is our function input. And we set it to a
function input scalar parameter. And we have it as
a normal multiplier. Now it's up to you how you want to do
that. But that can make things a little bit stronger. If you
need to, we notice we have a multiply in here into the red
channel, and also into the B channel here from the
function input we have in place, we have a green
multiplying here. Now, you don't necessarily have to take
this route. But this is one way to be able to edit this
to do a quick multiply control if you needed. That's
up to you. Or you can just simply plug in a multiply a
normal in here and just magnify its strength. In this case, we
have it so it's using a little bit of a panda output
for it. Over here, we have a texture sample that we're
using with a lerp. This is to make it so that we can go
into the roughness. And we also have a use to spread the
effect. I just have it set to a 0.5, you're more than
welcome to do so also. And then finally, we have the
simple lerp that we're using with a input tint for the
bark and to also darken the bark if we need to here. So
those options are in place. We're going to go ahead and
hit apply on this one, we want to make sure also that
expose the library like I mentioned before, you can
simply click on the grid to do so and turn that on. Now
for some reason, you don't see it coming up in your
parent material, it's gonna pull up with parent
material that we made, double click on that guy. Let's
drag him into the scene because he kind of went off
screen. There's a few things we need to keep in mind
when looking at the parent material. For one, we want
to make sure that we are set in the right spot. And
what I mean by that we want to make sure that our
layers or material functions are able to be accessed. I
just said apply on mine, but I'm probably more than
likely going to have to do a save. Let's see if m f m f
material function, new moss pops up. So let's go ahead
and look for it. So we'll do m f underscore new. There it
is new moss. Let's pull that up. And then we'll also
bring up our new wood that we have. So let's go ahead
and do that too. So let's do m f underscore new. Ah,
looks like new wood didn't come up. Let's hit apply.
And if for some reason they don't come up, you can save
if you need to. I'm just not doing save because I do use
this class quite often. There you go. It would.
Awesome. And you'll see we have the normal multiplier, we
have the 10 control and the final result. Let's let me
show you how this all comes together. So our wood normal,
we can basically keep our finger on the S key. And now
we have a scalar and we can call this wood normal. And
again, you don't have to set it up the way I did, you
can keep it a little more linear. And we'll set that to
one as a default. We also have the tint, what would
our tint be? Now again, your tint is up to you. What
kind of texture you want, we're gonna use a three
constant vector. In this case, you'll see we have a V
three. So I keep my finger to three key left click.
There we go. And then you can choose whatever brown
color you think works. So in this case, I'll do
something like this, and then lower that to, I think
that works right there. For now, we can always change
it later, can make it darker reminds me a little
bit lighter. We'll put it into the tint. Now we want
to use a, a layer blend is simple in here. And we
can do that by simply going in here and typing in
Matt. And you'll see there's a lot of layered in
here, which is really great. We have them all laid
out for you. So you can use them if you need, but
layer and they'll do blend. And then we're going to
put underscore simple. There he goes layer, matte
layer blend, simple. And we have the base, which
is going to be the wood, we have the moss now
again, you can make moss just as robust as you did
with the wood setup. But I kept mine simple, we
just need the input to be the top material. And
then finally, we can have an alpha. Now the alpha
you kind of want it to align to the world. This
is why I made this here. And to be doing to
do that, we want to type in a world aligned
to blend. So world, align and blend. There we
go, we gotta make sure you type it correctly.
World aligned blend, there we go. And I'm gonna
hit the one key to add a and it's up to
you how you much strength you want this to come
in via the blunt sharpness, I'm going to just
set that to 10. And we're going to set that to
the sharpness here. And then we have a blend
bias, I think a negative one works fine for
that, we can also just promote the variable if
we wanted to, and pull the blunt bias over and
make that a negative one. There you go. And
you can promote these as you need since it's
a parent material. So you want to make an
instance of it, you're more than welcome to do
so. I'm going to pull this alpha into the alpha
channel. And we want to make it so that we are
collapsing this. So we simply just get the
final output. Now to be able to do that, you
want to go ahead and go in here and say use
material attributes. When you do this collapses
to one final destination. And we pull that
execution string into here. And voila, we got
moss right there. Now I'm going to hit apply
on this one. Let's go to where that's a hat or
it lives. We're going to apply it on the sphere.
And now you can see all the mines a little
more green and nuclear. You can see, if I
rotate this, the moss will always end up on
the top. Pretty great to use that world
alignment with it. And again, we can choose how
strong these things are coming in with our
tent with our overall look and feel. If we go
here, we play with some of these numbers, say we
mess with the blend sharpness, increase that to
like 80 and hit apply. You'll see the change in
real time, you'll see that it's covering more
the wood, when we do that. And we can change
this to we can say blend sharpness slash
coverage on here, if you wanted to. And
that's really up to you. And again, you can
expose this and any of the other parameters.
But I hope overall, you get an idea of what
you can do for the material functions, to be
able to create a blend of material, stacking
them on top each other. Here's a more
complicated one, using a blend of material.
If we open this one up, this is one that I
created for Disney. We're going to pop this
open for some of their training. And it's no
you can probably guess why that it's new. And
what I mean by complicated, it's just a
little little bit of a loose interpretation. It's
not that complicated, really. But you'll see
there's a blended angle corrected normal in here
to blend between the snow and the rock. That
actually is very helpful to use. I'm using the
texture coordinates in here and multiply and a
texture sample in here. But you'll notice I
have a material function of snow cover. So it's
almost like a different type of approach, where
we don't have two material functions in the
front end, we have a material function kind of in
the back end. If we double click on that snow
cover, you'll see that I have it all broken down
or we haven't make material attributes. We
have a input base, let's go full screen. We
have a function input uses a bridge to create a
new functions and items to layer. And
especially in this case, you'll see we also
have a snow function here, brought in the mat
layer function we have in this case used to
flip the snow in the right direction. So if we
need to do that we can, we have a height lerp with
two height maps, we have a mat layer blend,
which is taking some of that information and
making it so that everything goes good with our
output. And you'll notice this is going in the
alpha kind of like what we have the other
material function. If we go down below, you'll see
that there is a base function input in here. And
we also have a few more nodes. And these allow
us to be able to get things a bit more
organized. And the fact that this node will help
create displacement if we need it. Now, this is
kind of an older system I made a very long time
ago, displacement you can now use within the
material, it was taken away for a while, and
then brought back. You'll notice here we do, we
are using blue color here for an up vector. So
we can use that RGB for positioning. And we go
over that in our visual effects. And I'm looking
at different ways to approach like foliage, other
things in our other classes and our foundational
material classes, you can use that RGB as XYZ. And
then we have a dot product here we bring in to
help calculate two vectors. And then we also clamp
this will make it keep things within a range and
used to help right here this lerp determine
whether we want the object to use the base
material or be covered in snow and the lerp itself,
we set a to one. And there you go. That's kind of
how that one set up. And you can see like I said
earlier, it's kind of on the back end here. And
then we have snow set up. So if we go into
that material, and look at it up close, now we
don't have an instance on this particular one. But
you can see how we can control the roughness and
a few other things in here. And you can even
make a thing called an NPC, which we'll cover
later, and which to have the snow cover more of
this shape. Well, that's it with this one. In the
next video, we're going to take a deeper dive
into a newer system of layered materials. And
I'm going to show you how to set this up and
get it going in the right direction. Thanks again.